I haven't been this excited about a
graphics card in a long time oh wait not
this
one this one W Brett that thing's so
tiny no way it's good at gaming congrats
you're right but you're not buying this
for gaming you're buying this to be a
media transcoding Powerhouse let's talk
about that so this is the Intel Arc A310
from Sparkle it's a single slot low
profile card with 4 gigs of vram and a
TDP of just 50 Watts those numbers
aren't very impressive are they well
jokes on you cuz that's what makes this
thing so great for just $100 you get a
card that will fit in pretty much any
chassis doesn't require external power
and is extremely good at transcoding BR
you keeps saying transcoding pretty sure
they don't allow that in Texas so for
those of you that only tuned in cuz you
saw a tiny GPU that would pair with your
tiny hands let me briefly explain what
transcoding is when you record watch or
Al download videos they have to be
packaged in something called a codec a
codec is essentially an algorithm for
how to digitally store that video and
there are quite a few out there some of
the most popular ones you hear about are
h264 h265 or hvc prores and most
recently av1 there are plenty more of
those out there but for the sake of this
video I'll just keep it high level now
the thing with codex is that they each
have their pros and cons h264 and h265
are the most popular popular ones in the
world cuz they're good at taking the raw
video format and compressing it down
into a much smaller file that is easier
to store and stream the downside to
those codecs though is that if you're a
content creator these formats are a
to edit you need a powerful
machine to decode or read these files
when editing there are some cool videos
out there that get into way more detail
about different codecs and why you would
prefer one over the other but all of
that to say the most popular codex in
the world suck to deal with unless you
have a dedicated engine built into your
processor that only exists to do
encoding and decoding transcoding there
are two major applications that require
transcoding hosting a media server and
video editing both things that I do on
the regular let's start with the media
server aspect I run Plex to host all of
my media but the concept is the same if
you're using jelly fin or whatever when
someone plays your content from your
server they are two ways they can stream
it direct or transcoded which one is
determined by quite a few things the
codec that the video is stored as the
resolution and the bit rate if the
client is compatible with all of those
then they can stream the media directly
and there isn't much the server Hardware
has to do however if one of those things
isn't compatible most commonly the bit
rate or the codec then the server will
have to transcode that media in real
time so that the client can watch it
true story I saw one of my buddies was
streaming Oppenheimer from mylex at 720p
but that's a 4K movie why watch it at
720p well it's an h265 video with a bit
rate of 35 megabits per second and
apparently his wife watched it too many
times in 4k and actually used up a lot
of their data cap so transcoding to the
rescue obviously this requires the
server to flex its muscles a bit here's
the thing though if your media is stored
as h265 h264 or even av1 then this
little GPU can actually do that for you
this is called Hardware transcoding
regular transcoding or software
transcoding is when the transcoding is
handled by the CPU for the record
software transcoding is much less
efficient than Hardware let me just show
you I'm going to load up six movies at
the same time on a Plex server that has
this A310 in it then I'm going to force
the server to live transcode all of that
at the same time this is a mix of 1080p
4K h264 and h265 media check this out
the A310 isn't missing a beat and has no
issues at all with all of these what
happens if we turn off Hardware
transcoding though yeah we're struggling
with just two streams this is the power
of dedicated encoders built into your
Hardware I know what you're thinking
Brett Nvidia and AMD both have built-in
transcoding hardware and so do Intel
processors with quick sync you are 100%
correct as for NVIDIA and AMD while they
make objectively better gpus for gaming
they're still surprisingly behind on
their media encoders and some of their
lower-end models don't even have any so
if you tell me for just $100 I can add a
card to my server that's going to
greatly reduce the workload on my CPU
when all my Plex users are streaming the
newest episode of Fallout sign me up
here are some raw transcoding numbers to
compare the different Hardware pause the
video if you want to study it like some
kind of nerd
the other reason why I love this video
card is for video editing now we already
covered codc and how certain ones can be
a pain to deal with unless you have
dedicated encoders for it well that's no
different when editing similar to how
most of the content you consume and
stream is done with h264 and h265 well
so is the content you create almost
every cell phone and camera is going to
record in h264 or h265 for the
efficiency reasons we mentioned before
this is great since it helps keep
storage requirements low but when it
comes time to edit yuck well good thing
we have our A310 cuz this thing choose
through some h264 I can slap multiple
videos on my timeline in a mix of crap
codecs and this little thing handles
playback and scrubbing surprisingly well
if you don't do content creation this
may not look impressive but let me show
you two other scenarios here's one with
my RTX 490 a $2,000 GPU gee that looks
about the same exactly now take a look
at what happens with no Hardware
transcoding yeah I I just threw up a
little bit okay yeah yeah nobody is
going to be editing video without some
kind of media encoder whether that be
Intel Quicks sync built into your
processor or any decent NV video or AMD
GPU let me throw this scenario at you
you build a thread Ripper build because
you want the most badass CPU on the
planet then you throw in an RTX 490 cuz
hey your wife already left you so why
not you then record some video in the
highquality yet efficient h264 10bit 422
that's going to run like ass but for
12th of the price of that RTX 490 you
can have this little guy and it will
pick up the slack for you all right yeah
the Plex scenario is obviously the more
popular and much more useful use case
for this thing if you're spending like
$5,000 on your editing rig then should
probably be recording in prores I mean
that's what my main camera is recording
but that's for another video this video
was to explain why why this Intel A310
is my favorite GPU out right now it's
not the fastest it doesn't have the most
vrm it's not particularly good at gaming
but it's cheap tiny uses very little
power and punches way above its weight
class for Hardware transcoding let me
know if you've snagged one of these and
what you think actually have its big
brother in the
a770 maybe it's time for a little
sibling competition video but that's all
I have for you today if you want to snag
one of these then please use my
affiliate link below so I can make like
a dollar or something if you like this
video then go ahead and drop a like if
you like content like this then
subscribe I want to give a huge shout
out to my YouTube members and my
patreons you guys are my super efficient
media encoder who can transcode 4K h264
10bit 422 content with no problem at all
y'all are dope and if you're still
watching you're an AMD RX 6400 thank you
so much and I'll see you in the next one
he
[Music]